successifs et ce créneau son nouvel
album qui s'appelle ben si ça vous plaît
les mutuelles se disent bien c'est bien
calaisis quelqu'un 40 ans près du ciel
c'est toujours aussi bien je sais pas je
vous en remercie
normalement je serai sans doute bien
l'essence encore entendu là bas si elles
vous plaisent c'est bien mais monsieur
connaissais pas mais c'est pas les
titres mais j'aime bien l'artiste mais
c'est vrai que dans l'esprit pour la
retourner au début c'était pas très
connu alors c'est un album que vous avez
fait et dit en collaboration avec notre
complice e pierre papadiamandis ce1
alors ce qui est bizarre effectivement
ces clichés d'abord la musique et après
vous faites les paroles alors que
d'habitude par excès d'un maire benjamin
c'est peut-être l'un vers 12h que nous
on a toujours travaillé quand même oui
en fait au départ vous vouliez pas
écrire de texte en particulier vous avez
dit comment les textes qu'on m'apporte
était tellement brûlés que je me suis
dit ça je peux en faire autant quoi
alors donc si vous n'avez pas la musique
je n'arrivais pas à partir quoi ses
seins détonateur ça j'aime pas écrire
donc ne peut pas faire des rimes toile
comme ça avec des grands cheveux longs
qui lui vend une fête pas les petits
poèmes que quelqu'un mais au musée
malraux c'est sa collecte donc je sais
pas te faire e alors musique les paroles
en fait non pas tellement d'importance
vous dites les gens écoutent bob dylan
depuis des années savent pas ce qu'ils
racontent et il fera chaud hier pour le
public au nom du temps alors frenchy
voulait fait à los angeles
vous dites je travaille à los angeles
parce que là-bas au moins je suis sûr
m'emmerder donc de bosser c'est vrai nom
mais je ne sais pas une vie qui me
passionne amusant mais enfin moi je ne
les retrouve pas ces c'est une ruse 80
km avec des pâtés de maisons à un océan
glacial
des boîtes qui ferment mal une heure du
matin enfin c'est pas très latin à quoi
tout cela quand même donc connaissez
vous donc quand on y est il qu'on tue
qu'on ne travaille que ça va ouais donc
là je suis sûre d'elle au studio à
l'heure je suis sale je bouge pas une
oreille
vous n'êtes pas eu envie vous ce chien
êtes vous installé à los angeles vient
pas du tout avant c'est marrant les
françaises ont du mal quand même avec la
californie en de bien exceptionnel et
que prendra les 83 vous avez été choqué
on parlait tout à l'heure de la guerre
d'irak j'avais été choqué par la
position de la france pendant la guerre
vous l'avez à trouver vous à moi je
l'approuvé gt
j'étais à los angeles d'ailleurs porte
ça s'est passé et j'appelais la france
pour avoir des nouvelles car aux états
unis c'était très très on s'est cru sous
sous de gaulle en ce sens tu en 58 par
les jeux sont plutôt sida c'est à dire
qu'il n'y avait heureusement pas d'infos
non vous êtes ont rarement vous exprimer
la tuberie disserter sur l'état du monde
au journal de 20 heures c'est pas mon
truc
non c'est pas mon truc parce que je
crois que c'est réservé à des gens qui
doivent savoir de quoi il parle s'y
connaître c'est pas mon cas je suis
comme tout le monde j'ai la formation
qu'on me donne c'est ça vous choque
ce pouvoir qu'on donne aux saltimbanques
d'une façon générale à la télévision de
donner leur avis sur l'état du monde
c'est ce qu'ils sont et qu'ils sont qui
me dérange c'est à dire que de dire ça
c'est bien ça c'est mal de disserter de
donner son avis son état d'âme sur des
choses que finalement que l'on connaît
pas assez je vais rejouer pour dire que
je sais pas moi tel tel pays vit sous
une dictature etc pour savoir quoi en
cause quand même mais bon je serais
incapable mois de jeu sera incapable de
dire ce qui se passait réellement en
irak avant la guerre vous l'avez fait
beaucoup vous sophie ça non je donne mon
avis ouais ouais mais je
je pense qu'on est quand même un petit
peu au courant mais sans faire de
politique mais à partir des éléments et
des informations que nous avons tous on
peut effectivement avoir un avis sur wii
sur les choses de ce monde quoi vous
vous le faites moi maintenant
non je ne fais pas moins pas du tout
aller quand même
non mais c'est la manipulation de la
presse qui vous dit une fois un truc et
c'est repris 40 fois pendant trois ans
dix ans après dans les journaux après
c'est là où l'on contrôle plus très bien
et c'est là où c'est dangereux et je
vous rejoins aussi un petit peu c'est
que il faut être aussi cohérent et une
fois qu'on se lance dans un débat il
faut aller au bout de ce débat il faut
pas le laisser tomber les trucs le drame
dans le métier c'est qu'on est très
souvent sollicités c'est très dur de
dire non quand on vous demande d'aider
des enfants malades ou deux mais après
il faut continuer coire et c'est
difficile d'être d'être comme ça
voilà deux continueront change constants
vers si vous aussi laurent
pourtant j'ai envie de vous demander
quand même la commande a passé la
semaine avec avec les retraites et les
gens dans la rue pas de métro pas
d'erreur pas de train vous vous
connaissez bien le problème parce que
votre père était la ratp votre mère
était visionner vos frères et vos soeurs
et 10 titres ce qui additionné
finalement pourriez y être au crédit
lyonnais aujourd'hui si vous n'avez pas
fait de choix devant la crise ils
reculent dans les séries vous en
pensez-quoi parce que vous toute ma
famille était là non vous êtes quand
même bien placé pour en parler je ne
sais pas enfin je dis simplement que il
ya quand même des gens qui ont raison
dans tout ça c'est que j'ai pas les gens
qui ont une vingtaine d'années dans peu
de temps
et puis qu'ils vieilliront je vois pas
comment ils pourront toucher des
retraites
donc c'est vrai que c'est aux gens qui
sont là en ce moment de faire un effort
me semble vous vous dites on est un pays
formidable d'un point de vue social mais
parfois on se demande si on n'est pas un
peu trop assisté à un honneur ah bah oui
mais enfin c on a pris l'habitude
c'est bien et c'est irréversible ah bah
non les droits qui sont acquis ouais
ouais d'accord
bakhit quand les mecs qui conduisent des
tgv pendant toujours la retraite à 50
ans même si charmant mais ils vont même
essayé dans quelques années plus tôt
alors on connaît votre amour du cinéma
eddy mitchell vous aider à bien tous
réaliser votre premier film qui cédant
pardon non j'ai pas eu l'argent en c'est
vrai parce que enfin tf1 décidé que
c'était fort parce qu'il faut bien rire
voilà qu'il est pareil si cher que ça
rebondit tout magnon pourrais jamais le
passé à 20h30 c'est un film de d'adultes
donc mais c'est pas grave vous aimez
quand même le cinéma
ao je vais toujours le cinéma je veux
faire comme au cinéma on va faire une
machine à remonter le temps